hello everyone and welcome to a very
exciting game from round two of the tata
still chess tournament 2022 it's magnus
carlsen versus anish giri and if you
remember after his world championship
championship match against yanni pomeshi
magnus said that he might not
defend the next time he's challenged to
wheelchair championship match unless it
is uh by alireza firuja
but he did say that he will try and
achieve the uh well so far unachievable
rating in classical time format of 2900
and it's not going to be easy because
you have to beat top level players uh
constantly for for a very long time or
have like one really really perfect
tournament uh and then maybe it can be
achieved so uh he played a espanko in
round one that game ended in the draw
magnus had a sort of an attempt at a
winning position but he missed the idea
if you guys watch the press conference
after the game magnus said all right i i
can see why the engines is saying that
so i don't want to debate it but
it was obviously due not too difficult
to spot so now he faces anishigiri and
that's uh never um
never easy as you've seen in the world
rapid and blitz championship uh anish
defeated magnus and he even winked at
the camera afterwards uh but okay that
being said let's check it out as this
game has quite a lot to offer so magnus
with the white pieces opens with d4 uh
knight to f6 by geary we have c for e6
knight to f3 and d5 so a standard
queen's gambit declined
and magnus goes for g3 he goes for the
catalan opening he's ready to develop
the bishop to g2 so bishop to e7 bishop
to g2 and here unease castles we have
castles castles in the now
finally d captures on c4
so what do you play here knight the a3 a
very very exotic uh choice by magnus uh
he's saying i want to reclaim the pawn
my knight is guarding b5 so i'm not
allowing pawn to b5 but also if you want
to capture my knight you can this will
mess up my pawn structure but i get to
have the bishop pair and you don't
so it's definitely best to do this on
each ghost for it even though it kind of
means going into carlson's preparation
but um yeah i mean you don't uh
sometimes people uh refuse to play the
best move in order to avoid someone's
preparation but anish of course goes
straight into it b captures an a3 and
now the shutter d7
and now the thing is if you go something
like 95 which is a move magnus it
definitely wants to play we're going to
play bishop to c6 that's how we defend
everything along this diagonal and after
knight captures the bishop captures and
it would be two bishops against two
knights uh with anish having um well uh
he's up upon but he has a double c pawn
magnus has a doubled a pawn uh perfectly
fine for for both players uh so instead
of this after bishop to d7 uh magnus
goes a4
and now we have bishop to c6 so the
bishop claims this diagonal we have
bishop to a3 as the a3 square was uh
freed for the bishop and now rook to e8
the rook on f8 was under attack so queen
to c2 now threatening to pick up the
pawn uh and you could defend it with
bishop to d5 but then you're kind of
saying okay this bishop is now basically
a pawn
and well you can't really keep it if
white doesn't allow it you can play
knight to d2 you could go after the pawn
trade of the light square bishops so uh
playable but not uh of any interest to
an issue would seem so here anish plays
knight b to d7 and it is now as of movie
11 that we have a completely new game
now magnus could capture on c4 with the
queen and then anish will win a temple
with knight to b6 but magnus first goes
to rook 8 to c1
and now anish went into a deep thing and
after some 30 minutes he played a6 and
okay now magnus wins back the pawn queen
captures on c4 and now knight to b6 and
what's interesting here is the situation
on the clock magnus says one hour and 36
minutes whereas anish is already down to
56 minutes so magnus
has more time than when he started
meaning that he's well within his
preparation uh but here after knight the
b6 not so much because um uh well not
now he also uh
is out of uh preparation or maybe he saw
it and then he just needs to remember uh
there are many possible retreat squares
for the queen queen to be four queen to
d3 queen to c two queen
where do you put the queen because the a
for pawn will fall uh it's only a matter
of uh
where anish will capture with the bishop
or with the knight so here magnus plays
the queen back to c3 and now uh if you
capture with the bishop it doesn't
really do all that much but capturing
with the knight
forces magnus to waste another tempo so
this is what geary goes for knight
captures on a4 and now queen to b3 and
now you have to be careful there are
some ideas of eliminating the defender
of the knight just winning uh material
here so anish has to figure out how to
continue here and he plays queen to d5
which is uh which is a fine move uh but
uh there was also the very interesting
um idea of just knight back to b6 and
then magnus would play rook captures on
c6 this pretty much forced and no doubt
something magnus had in his home
analysis um maybe not this ex exact same
position but i'm uh
fairly sure the the ideas exist uh well
uh regardless of maybe a move here and
they're being played differently so here
95
queen captures on d4 and now knight
captures on c6 attacking the queen and
the idea is once the queen moves we're
going to deliver knight to e7 check and
open up and attack towards the rook here
so
it's going to be fine queen c4 let's say
97 check king to h8 we're going to play
bishop captures on a8 and now after lazy
queen captures eight captures uh rook
captures an a8 and we would have this
position where anish would be up upon uh
but still it's a it's a bishop in knight
versus tonight so uh the bishop would
probably enjoy some counter play here
but this should not be you know better
for anyone so instead after queen to b3
anish went for queen to d5 he offers a
queen trade right away
but magnus still goes for rook captures
on c6 and now you can play queen
captures on b3 first to trade the queens
because after a captures the knight is
also attacked and once you capture the
rook we're gonna capture the knight on
a4 and we're just much much better here
so instead after rook captures on c6
queen captures on c6 and now magnus gets
to play knight to e5 so you can see how
all of this was made with with the plan
of bringing the knight
to e5 and look at these bishops bishop
slicing here bishop slicing here the
knight on a uh beautiful e5 square the
queen attacking
this the the rook might come to b1 or c1
put pressure on this
pawn then the f7 might become weak so
there are there's a lot of potential in
the position of course if black plays
perfectly
then it won't happen but uh that's why
uh we we play chess so queen to b5
and now of course magnus avoids the
queen trade queen to c2 uh and now the
situation is one hour for magnus some 45
minutes for a niche
and the position is well it's very scary
only one move is pretty much good for
anish and i will show it because it
wasn't played but you have to bring the
knight back with knight to b6 uh point
being that after bishop captures and b7
you can't really move the rook uh if you
play rook rook 88 or something then
bishop to c6 and white just wins so the
point is after bishop captures on b7 you
have to play knight to c4 it's not easy
to spot but it's uh it's there for a
reason bishop captures an a8 knight
captures an a3 attacking carlsen's queen
queen to c6 and now for example queen
captures an e2 bishop to b7 and now
queen captures on a2 and yes it's uh
not not uh all that uh aesthetically
pleasing uh but black will black will be
fine here for example knight g4 we want
to remove the defender of the rook here
king f8 now the king defends the rook
let's say knife captures g captures
queen f3 uh white would have uh a lot of
great great moves here but still uh
if you play perfectly you should you
should hold it uh so that's probably why
anisha decided against this move and he
played knight to d5 but knight to d5
doesn't work and it's not uh
well it doesn't work for one very
specific reason and that is uh rook to
b1
rook to b1 or bishop to e4 it's all
in the air because bishop to e4 is just
winning even more space for white it
will force g6 and that's going to weaken
black's position much more in the future
we might have if g6 has played some
knight g for knight d7 ideas with the
df6 and h6 squares being weak uh but
okay here magnus went for rook to b1 and
now it's not easy for the black queen
here look at the bishop here look at the
knight look at the rook look at the
queen all of these squares are
controlled by white and you simply don't
have a good square for the queen anish
plays queen to a5 this is the only
square available for the queen and now
magnus plays bishop captures on d5
and this is not
the most precise way bishop to e4 is a
bit more more precise first threat in
the h7 pawn and only after g6 then we
capture here captures capture so now
rook captures on b7 and this is now very
very weak for black it's pretty much the
position that we got in the actual game
only without the weakening with the
the g6 move so instead bishop captures
and d5 was played right away and here
anish thought about the position for a
little bit but he played e captures on
d5 he didn't want to give up the knight
on a4
even though that's exactly what you
should do here after queen captures on
d5 queen captures on a4
uh now it's possible to play f6 and
after the knight moves queen captures
sun a2 and it's still bishop and denied
for a rook but black will have some
counter play white is of course better
but maybe nothing uh decisive so instead
after bishop captures on the five on
each plate e captures on the e5 he
wanted to hold everything together and
now rook captures on b7 similar to what
we talked about only without the
inclusion of g6
and now there really isn't a good move
here uh for for an issue you could try
something like knight to c3 that as it's
well the the c7 pawn is hanging you
can't move the queen the knight is
hanging
it's just a
terrible position for black and if
something like c3 it looks like it can
be played because you block the queen's
attack towards this pawn also you remove
the knight from a4 as a target but
there's a bishop to b4 and now after
queen captures on a2 we can play queen
captures on c3 and again it's not very
good for black so instead anish played
c5 which makes sense you block the
bishop you try and get this then the
knight falls but the position is now
completely winning for magnus so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the winning idea while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting uh the
the winning idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show of
course the movie is queen to f5 we just
uh bring more firepower to that f7
square and that's how we win this you
could go for for captures right away but
for example if knight captures here you
allow this annoying queen to e1 check
king to g2 and queen captures an e2 and
well there's just no reason to allow
this now you don't have queen f5 because
queen e4 check can just trade off the
queens and this would be a draw at best
so instead queen to f5 this is deadly
you are now threatening queen captures
on f7 followed by queen captures on g7
checkmate so here rook to f8 you have to
defend but now knight captures on f7 uh
and here again you can capture because
just captures with checkmate uh so here
queen to d8 a beautiful move by anish uh
but uh also an an insufficient one uh
his idea is that uh if
magnus goes for knight captures here
then he can capture the queen on f5 but
magnus just placed d captures on c5 uh
if you go for knight to the h6 it looks
very nice because you can't capture due
to checkmate due to checkmate
but you can just move the king and now
white really has nothing better than to
repeat and then play the move that he
actually played in the game so here
magnus plays d captures on c5 it's
possible to play with the bishop but
magnus prefers to keep the bishop in the
game because the knight on a4 isn't
doing all that much so here queen to f6
offering a queen trade and now magnus
just trades because the resulting end
game is winning for him so queen
captures g captures and now knight to h6
with check the rook controls the seventh
rank so you have to move to h8 it's the
only move now comes c6 not only
advancing the pawn but opening up a
discovery here so rook f the c8 and now
c7 and now the position is beautiful for
white this rook can't go anywhere uh
this rook also doesn't really have all
that much to do we're just gonna attack
it probably night if five night here or
night here we'll attack the rook and
that's pretty much winning the game so
here anish tries a little trick knight
to c3 but it's not uh
the trick doesn't work his idea was if
magnus goes maybe knight f5 maybe he can
play rook captures on c7 uh for example
rook captures knight b5 but it's still
not enough after rook to d7 knight
captures on a3 yes you win back uh
material but real captures on the e5
we're in an in in an end game where
magnus is up two pawns this will be
completely winning for magnus so instead
uh magnus says um uh all right uh that
might be a too too big of a grind
perhaps so let's just go bishop to b2
keep the bishop on the board and now
let's just play what uh what i came here
to do
d4 and now knight to f7 with check king
g7 and not knight to d6 attacking the
rook here and now you could capture the
e2 pawn with check but it doesn't really
do anything so king to g6 was played and
now king to f1
magnus has 40 minutes on the clock
whereas anish has only one minute on the
clock he played knight to b5
attacking the knight here but now he
basically forces knight captures on c8
and magnus cannot wait any longer so
knight captures on c8 rook captures and
now a4
forcing the the trait here knight
captures on c7 bishop captures on d4 now
comes knight to e6 attacking the bishop
and here magnus just played bishop to e3
guarding the c1 square so we don't have
any checks and also keeping an eye on
this knight so the knight can't really
go anywhere
and well the bishop is just a beautiful
piece here magnus is up two pawns and of
course this is a completely winning end
game uh anish knows that magnus knows
that ended therefore he was in this
position on move 36 that anish giri
resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it so it was a pretty pretty
crazy stuff for magnus here sort of uh
play playing a little bit like do over
here only okay a bit more more
safely uh but yeah it seems that he uh
employed the dubo recipe here enjoying
uh you know a comfortable disadvantage
uh you know before equalizing and then
you know just running your opponent over
and even though magnus drew his first
game in the tata still this brings him
much much closer to the
uh to the uh his uh actual goal of
becoming the first player to be rated 2
900 in classical chess uh so we'll see
how it goes plenty more rounds to go uh
he might win all of them he might lose
some so you know he might even lose
rating in this tournament we'll see how
it goes and as a lot of you are
interested magnus did not wink at the
camera after this game finished i know
you guys were really wondering about
that uh so yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it i would like to thank
link mike wagner uh joseph henderson
frank combs and ian toplas for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event
until it finishes uh thank you i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day